everyone DC is celebrating Batman's 80th
anniversary this year and a milestone
that huge calls for an epic shout-out
montage so to kick things off happy
birthday backer happy birthday Batman
happy birthday Batman happy birthday
Batman happy birthday Batman
happy birthday Batman holy happy
birthday Batman happy birthday Batman
happy 80th birthday Batman Batman
happy birthday Bruce I mean Batman
happy birthday Batman happy birthday
Batman from Batwoman happy 80th birthday
Batman I still want to be you when I cry
happy birthday Batman I hope you have
some good cake happy 80th happy 80th
birthday
happy 80th birthday Batman happy
birthday Batman happy birthday Batman
you old bastard happy birthday happy
birthday Batman 80 years Stang Bruce
Wayne looking good keeping it tight
happy thank you for all you do you
deserve a great one happy birthday happy
80th anniversary to the Dark Knight
happy birthday Batman we love you we
appreciate you peers - how many more
years hundreds more years
happy birthday Batman take flight
brother happy 80th anniversary to the
Dark Knight Batman I owe you everything
happy birthday Batman happy birthday
Batman happy birthday Batman
happy birthday Batman lots of love dad
happy birthday Batman eight years old
you look great happy birthday Oh
happy birthday Batman you're 80 so be
careful on the stairs with that cape
happy 80th birthday Batman we were my
first Halloween costume Batman happy
80th birthday Batman happy 80th birthday
Batman happy birthday to the one and
only Batman and you changed my life
happy birthday Batman I love you happy
80th birthday Batman happy 80th birthday
Batman we're uh sorry about your parents
happy 80th birthday Batman
happy birthday pad man happy 80th
birthday Batman hey happy birthday
Batman thank you so much for all these
years of service couldn't do it without
you and hope you stick around for a long
time after
[Music]